but i'd love what minor league clubs do
now and how they changed the name five
school list innings for him and that's
gonna be a fair ball for tapia so top
he's gonna stretch this out
to two
a lead off double and a runner in
scoring position more importantly jeff
well in a seven game hit streak too for
tapia let's not forget to give tapia
also a round of applause on the subaru
super bowl because that's career hit
number 300
and it's it's almost fitting that he
goes right down the line
because that's what he's been doing now
27 opposite field hits
well i think right here too you're going
to see garrett possibly try to push a
bunt past
garrett that's where speed will come
into play and garrett does put the bunt
down
on the right side and
he'll leave tapia over at third
put some pressure on the marlins with
charlie blackman up to bat
so charlie fires away he'll drive in the
run right away why not grab another rbi
continue up the list charlie and then
also a nine-game hitting streak for
charlie but you want to talk about a
manufactured run this is exactly it
charlie stays on that curveball on the
subaru super mo from braxton garrett
just smokes one right back up the middle
to get the rockies on the board right
away 33 rbis now on the season for chuck
nasty
how about that
charlie blackman hustling down the line
blackman the runner at first one out in
the third
garrett knocks it down
looks at second but he'll take the out
at first
yeah this would have been hard to get to
originally yes but after the bobble
charlie blackman pretty good speed
getting out of the glove that's the
difference
between a double play and just that out
at first base so runner into scoring
position how good they are right now
anyway it's unbelievable but how many
were
we're there how about that pulling a hit
over to left field charlie's coming home
so the rockies will get another run on
the board it's two to nothing
jonathan dazzle with another hit
not hit particularly hard
it was a fastball it just cut in onto
the
the hand you can hear the the crack of
the bat
and not a solid crack the bat actually
cracked as it went over the head of chas
jism
curtis originally drafted by the twins
out of the university of texas
and tapia fires off right away that'll
go into left field and he'll turn on the
wheels to head into second easily
this isn't a replay
that we had in the first inning it's
just a replay of this pass hit in the
28th opposite field hit the slider on
the subaru super mode just doesn't get
down and this left up and tapia
says i know what to do with that pitch
i'll take it the other way for hit
number 301 in his career
just didn't seem like anything would
fall he's had some strikeouts in there
but now he's back to doing garrett
things
that's on the ground and tapia is going
to get around it so it'll move the
runner up to the third it's safe for
garrett hampson
that's what speed will do for you
well last night garrett almost beat one
out look where the shortstop is so where
did he have to go he had to go deep in
the hole he probably should have
backhanded that because by the time he
got around it
and then set his feet watch as he gets
around and sets his feet well garrett's
going to outrun that baseball
running hard out of the box he knows
right now i got a chance to beat this
out for a base hit
starting at second base last night moved
over to third starting at third tonight
and that's me
ball's going to get away and easily home
is tapia
rocks up three to nothing
lineup card turns over for jazz chisholm
junior a double his last time up
into left center field of base hit
that's going to bring home birdie
and jazz with an rbi
marlins are on the board 3-1 here in the
fifth
well jazz has had some of the best
swings
of the night against gomber
absolute laser for a double in the third
that came on a slider this is a fastball
up
we've seen this a lot more from jazz of
late willing to go the other way stay
inside the baseball
pretty simple approach
the ball up and lines it into left
marlins
cracked the scoreboard
and hopefully a hit
he's going to go head to second and
brendon rogers is going to get held up
at third
so that one huey on the line
that one was
1-0 and joel hit it hard to the
shortstop that's gonna bring a run home
for the rockies 4-1
getting his job done
he's just found a way to continue to do
it
and with the shortstop chisholm junior
having to back up he couldn't come get
this ball because of the hop would have
ate him up so he had to back up
and then he wisely decided not to come
home because if he does brendan's going
to score
and then you wouldn't get the out
at first
here's adam duvall
a couple of strikeouts against gomber
adam duvall balls go out to left field
too
that's a two-run homer for adam duvall
and the marlins get a little bit closer
here in the sixth inning
we talk about the ability to extend the
ability to go down and
take pitches
out over the plate and drive them out
he's got as much power as anybody in the
game when he can use it get right there
jesus aguilar they've only matched up
one other time jesus for one against
michael
here's the 1-2 and a big swing from
aguilar that out to right field and
shirley blackman tracking it back
what a catch by charlie what a catch by
charlie and michael gibbons getting the
rockies out of some trouble
they'll maintain their 4-3 lead as we go
to the eighth
[Music]
faces loaded two outs and a 4-3 rockies
lead
here's the 1-2 and that goes
to the left side mcmahon fires and
rockies will take the victory on the
road
how about it colorado
they're going to look at something i'm
not sure what they're gonna look at
here's the replay at first
see if they're gonna
check if fuentes foot was on the bag
and there we go now it's a final and
official bud black his 300th win